Brett is in Orange County hey Brett
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thanks for having me certainly how can I
help
well my wife and I just got married
about a month ago yes there's actually
on our one-month anniversary
congratulations Rick or thank you very
much we're going through financial peace
we're about five weeks in and we're on
baby step number two we're planning on
to be here for a little while but we're
going down to do it my question is I'm a
self-employed my chiropractor and I
don't know whether I should pay my
practice debt first or my personal debt
first I don't know what the best way
would be to handle that well legally
speaking it's all personal debt you saw
it you sign for the debt personally or
you didn't get the loan right so if
you're in a business is an escort
yeah but the escort that you have a
personal guarantee on the loan right
yeah and if you don't have a personal
guarantee on it you when they got in the
loan so how much do you owe on your
practice telling the practice is about
70,000 okay and that's just a bank loan
or what the equipment credit cards and a
sort of business loan
oh so it's a series of loans it's not
one loan right okay so the credit cards
are personal loans too I mean
technically speaking this is all in your
mind and correctly from an accounting
standpoint you call it business debt but
my point is legally that that business
doesn't exist as far as those lenders
are concerned they're looking at you and
you are on the hook for that so you got
seventy thousand there what do you got
quote-unquote at home at home would be
about 265 counting your mortgage no my
student loans are about 220 of that holy
crud yeah
what's the other 45 30 and credit card
and 15 on a car please tell me you're
making some money yep so my wife brings
home about 130 pre-tax and I this year I
brought home just about 70 pre-tax so
far part of the reason is it's having to
pay so much obviously for my payment
through the business by the time it gets
to me and through taxes that end up
being significantly lower but okay so
what's your top line on your business so
so far this year I've collected about
two hundred thousand okay and not
counting debt payments what is your
overhead about six thousand a month okay
so you're making a profit that's taxable
yeah of about a hundred and fifty one
hundred and forty well by the time I pay
the minimum payment through the company
no no payments are not expensable
okay I'm talking about your profit and
loss statement your taxable income over
there before you pay debt payments is
about a hundred and thirty it sounds
like seventy two sixty six thousand
dollars a month okay and you make two
hundred thousand top line and if the if
your overhead non debt overhead is so
you made one twenty eight thousand
taxable income and she made a hundred
thirty so you got two hundred sixty
thousand on our income that's good news
okay good and now we're gonna pay down
and yeah now that you know that debt
over at the business you pay your
minimum payments on everything and so
the answer to your overall question is I
would just list these things smallest to
largest put them all together because a
they're all personal debt and you know
if you want to pay the minimum payments
over at the office on the on the what
you've categorized as business debt
that's fine that's your minimum payments
but in terms of how you order your debt
snowball which one do we pick on next
we'll jump back and forth between the
house and the office bye
having one list of debts smallest to
largest so the last thing you're going
to end up paying is your student loan
debt okay it'll be the biggest one right
right and and you got seventy plus you
got about another 45 at home of other
odds and ends so you got a hundred and
ten you're gonna wipe through in the in
the top of your debt snowball on the
bottom of that snowballs your $225,000
debts not your student loan debt does
that make sense yep we're gonna jump
we're gonna integrate them as if they
are one list even though you may write
the checks out of two different
locations is that okay
sure yeah you're doing good man you
you're you're getting this you're
working this through you got a lot of
debt my brother but you're you got it
good news is you got two hundred sixty
thousand our income to attack it with
and so and you got two sixty senators
you've got three hundred thousand almost
over three hundred thousand total three
and thirty thousand making one making
two sixty so yeah you can probably do
this in three years but you're gonna be
on beans and rice rice and beans you're
not gonna be living orange county life
you're gonna be living no life work all
the time spend no money pay down debt
because here's the cool thing you get
the other side of this and you don't
have any payments with that income ding
ding the stuff you'll be able to do oh
my goodness
it'll be worth it three years that's
what I do